Not a day goes by without the internet nearly
shutting down completely over a breaking news
story.
The most recent threat of total implosion
came on May 16th, when word got out that Warner
Bros. and director Matt Reeves were nearing
a deal with Robert Pattinson to become the
new Batman, taking over for Ben Affleck.
Even though Pattinson has been in plenty of
films, most only know him from his role as
the glistening vampire Edward Cullen in the
Twilight film saga.
So to imagine him donning the cape and cowl
in Reeves' The Batman was simply too much
for people.
Pattinson fans, those who aren't down for
the English actor to portray the famous superhero,
and everyone in between is completely freaking
out about his reported casting.
One person tweeted:
"It is official, the DCEU should be canceled.
This is a HORRIBLE choice to play the character."
Someone else practically shouted into the
Twitter-sphere when Pattinson's name started
trending on the site:
"Robert Pattinson getting casted proves that
@DCComics @TheDCUniverse @warnerbros HATES
its fans!!!
Awful just awful!!!
I've never been so disappointed in a Batman
casting!!!
Dammit!!!"
Anger over Pattinson assuming the Bat-mantle
from Affleck got so intense that naysayers
started various online petitions demanding
that Warner Bros. and Reeves replace the actor
with someone else.
At the end of the day, it's unlikely that
any of the appeals will amount to much more
than extra internet noise.
"And Bruce Wayne?
Why are you dressed up like Batman?"
The other side of social media couldn't be
happier about Pattinson lining up to become
the new Batman, and have some advice for those
who are criticizing the casting choice two
years ahead of the film's June 2021 release
date.
One user posted on Twitter:
"Robert Pattinson is the PERFECT.
CASTING.
FOR.
BATMAN."
Another fan rallying behind Pattinson pointed
to the actor's work outside of the Twilight
franchise as evidence that he can deliver
an incredibly powerful performance, and will
likely do the same when it comes to Bruce
Wayne in The Batman.
"Robert Pattinson playing Batman sounds awesome.
The man truly proved himself as a wonderful
performer in these few years and I'm certain
he'll play the part well."
A Twitter user by the name of Josh Price also
urged those skeptical about Pattinson's ability
to give a solid performance as Batman to check
out the actor's post-Twilight movies namely
Good Time, Cosmopolis, and The Rover.
He wrote:
"If you're in any doubt over Robert Pattinson
being cast as Batman because you only know
him from Twilight, then please watch these
three movies.
Then try to tell me he isn't an amazing choice."
Eisner Award-winning comic book writer and
Hugo Award-nominated novelist Saladin Ahmed
gave a tongue-in-cheek response to the uproar.
In a post shared to his Twitter page, Ahmed
pointed out the irony in the fact that many
of the people mad about Pattinson portraying
Batman are apparently failing to remember
how inherently silly the costumed vigilante
really is.
Ahmed tweeted:
"'ugh [they] picked an angsty pretty boy who
spent his early 20s pretending to be a vampire'
I have bad news for you about batman."
JoBlo editor-in-chief Paul Shirey had arguably
the most pragmatic reaction to all the hullabaloo:
he reminded everyone that three previous Batman
actors, Affleck, Christian Bale, and Michael
Keaton, starred in their fair share of so-so
films before they became Batman.
Some of them were downright goofy.
"It's showtime,"
In Shirey's eyes, people shouldn't gauge Pattinson's
acting abilities solely on Twilight, as they
wouldn't judge Affleck, Keaton, or Bale on
their wackier pre-Batman works.
The best thing is just to withhold extreme
judgements one way or the other about Pattinson
succeeding Affleck as the Caped Crusader until
The Batman hits theaters in 2021.
Hopefully once The Batman gets closer to its
premiere date, the Pattinson-lovers and the
Pattinson-haters can settle their differences
and a general consensus about the situation
can be established.
For now, keep it civil.
Remember, Gotham's watching.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about superhero
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.